hey guys it's Angelica with Mac's tech
and today we're going to be playing
games on two of the best tablets out
right now this is the iPad pro and over
here we have the new Galaxy Tab as six
that just came out recently before there
was a tablet as 5e but the processor was
pretty slow but now with s6 we have an
improved processor that's much faster so
now we're gonna compare these two and
see how they do alright guys so we're
gonna start with the 2018 iPad pro first
and we're gonna be playing asphalt 9 to
begin with Oh get on my way boy just
kidding I'm just kidding sorry I know
what I'm doing
where's it banana peels can I get banana
peels alright so far it feels really
really smooth having experience any lag
or anything yet sorry bud you okay
okay sir oh he's fine and the audio to
that audio was really good it sounds
pretty equal on both sides I'm just
trying to have a good time and hurt some
people this is dangerous
alright guys so now we're gonna be
transferring to the Galaxy Tab s 6 ok
this is this is really interesting
it's definitely actually pretty laggy
not very lucky but it's nowhere near
smooth that's an iPad pro oh no I don't
know how we got first I'm pretty sure
we're dead whoo oh my goodness sorry
buddy well uh oops sorry
oh my gosh I'm so I'm so clumsy oh my
goodness oh I am so sorry sir but
honestly is still pretty good just
definitely playable it's not like it
doesn't have to be perfect but the iPad
pro I prefer it's definitely much much
better performance wise all right guys
here we are in modern combat 5 poise I
don't think I'm gonna make it
not today fighting for my life
you can't kill me who are you shooting
yet everything's really really really
smooth super super fast there's no F
zero complaints everything is literally
perfect and we're going to raise the
frames are ready to make friends and not
kill anyone
where are you looking
this is war boys this isn't a game you
think this is a game no no no oh my
goodness oh it's you it's the first one
he's stressing me out hey we did the
boys oh man all right guys now here we
are in vain glory on the 2018 iPad pro
scarf who are you oh my goodness why are
they all here No
dude everything's so perfect on the iPad
pro all right guys no here we are in
vainglory on the Galaxy Tab s6 point you
wanna fight no my abilities are but you
know what I don't need to know I'm not
experiencing any issues or new lag or
any anything like that oops oops No oh
my gosh
so cute oh man oh that is a sad game
alright guys so I did notice a couple
differences between these two tablets
when it came to gaming the first one is
that the iPad pro is definitely more
powerful like when it comes to the
processor compared to the Galaxy Tab and
asphalt 9 I'm pretty sure was playing at
60 frames per second while the Galaxy
Tab a 6 was playing at 30 so that made a
big difference because it was much more
laggy and the framerate was dropping
quite a bit on the Galaxy Tab but on the
iPad pro was completely smooth the
entire time there was no lagging or any
frame rates dropping no when it came to
vainglory in modern combat 5 there
wasn't much of a difference performance
wise they were both really good the
audio quality and both are really really
good both sides of speakers on both
tablets are really even one thing to
notice is that the Samsung Galaxy tabs
are definitely much more comfortable to
hold in the hand the iPad pro is it's
pretty square in boxy so after after
holding it for a while it kind of digs
into your hands it's pretty sharp on the
edges too it's not very rounded and
smooth so if you're gonna be playing for
a long time it's gonna get a little bit
uncomfortable when it comes to
performance the iPad pro does do a bit
better and in some games it can play
60fps while the Galaxy Tab can't and
that's definitely drawback is you're
gonna like rare asphalt 9 there was a
lot of lagging that I was experiencing
so that's definitely a drawback via let
me know which one of these you would
prefer to buy and if you did purchase
one let me know which one and why and
how your
Barings is going if you guys like to see
our detailed comparison between these
two tablets click over here and click
above to subscribe thank you guys for
watching this is of an angelica with max
tech and i'll see you in the next one
[Music]